[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALIK GEORGE: What's going on?
I'm Malik.
MILES GEORGE: I'm Miles.
We're Malik and Miles.
MALIK GEORGE: And we're
MIT undergraduates.
MILES GEORGE: And we're going to
talk about the top five reasons
to study the brain.
MALIK GEORGE: Coming in at 5.
MILES GEORGE: You can find the
cure to any biological disease
that affects the brain.
Number four--
MALIK GEORGE: You can
literally learn the biology
that governs behavior.
Coming in at three--
MILES GEORGE: You can understand
the most complex thing
in the known universe.
MALIK GEORGE:
Besides us, that is.
GROUP: Nah.
MILES GEORGE: Number two.
MALIK GEORGE: Pop quiz.
What is the only organ
that has named itself?
[BUZZER]
[CROWD CHEERING]
MILES GEORGE: It's the brain.
MALIK GEORGE: And
finally, number one.
MILES GEORGE: And it's
the most important.
Neurons have the coolest
shape of literally any cell.
[MARKER SOUNDS]
Like, a normal cell is like
this, but a neuron is like--
[MARKER SOUNDS]
If they're not
animating this, this
is going to look really weird.
MALIK GEORGE: But if
you're not convinced
this will change your mind.
One, and two, and--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We'll see you next time.
MILES GEORGE: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]